new information suggests the corona
virus was spreading rapidly in the u.s.
much earlier than first thought only 23
cases in several major cities had been
reported by March first when very
limited testing was being done
the New York Times used a Northeastern
University model to estimate there could
have been about 28,000 infections in
those cities by that time dr. Jon LaPook
spoke with one of the northeastern
researchers John it appears the virus
also took lives in the u.s. a lot
earlier than we thought
that's right Anthony we thought that the
first u.s. death had occurred in
Washington State in late February now it
turns out that there was an earlier
death in California about three weeks
earlier and as some states are looking
to reopen there are still a lot of
questions about the early spread of the
virus we project by early March
thousands of cases across the country
dr. Alessandro Vespa eonni is a
professor at Northeastern University in
Boston his research team has been
modeling the spread of corona virus they
believe it likely began in the u.s. in
January and by mid February there were
about 50 new infections per day those
cases were not detected because if you
don't ask you don't detect Thank You mr.
vice president last week CDC director
dr. Robert Redfield said the US had been
successful in tracing the spread of
kovat 19 to February 27th this country
only had 14 cases but a New York Times
analysis of the university's modelling
estimates by March 1st the number of
cases was much higher likely reaching
nearly 30,000 in five US cities about
10,000 of them in New York where social
distancing would not be enforced for
another two weeks I think the major
problem was lack of testing dr. Matthias
knurl is a researcher at NYU Langone
health the fact that this virus can
spread asymptomatic play from person to
person without causing any disease was
underappreciated until recently through
genetic analysis his team found most
corona virus infections in the u.s. did
not come directly from China
instead they largely came from China to
Europe and from Europe to the United
States travel from China to the US was
curtailed On January 31st but traveled
from Europe continued freely for more
than a month if I could turn the clock
back and go back in time there will be
two things that I think will be critical
one of them would be to put a mask on
everybody in the city the second thing
would be to start aggressively testing
everyone who was traveling from outside
I think it's important to learn from our
mistakes this is not the last pandemics
that we are facing data from a
preliminary state survey released
Thursday found more than 20% of people
randomly tested in New York City were
found to have antibodies to coronavirus
these are people who were infected and
who developed the antibodies to fight
the infection four weeks ago five weeks
ago six weeks ago in Santa Clara County
California officials say CDC testing has
revealed the first known corona virus
death in the u.s. occurred on February
6th not February 29th as previously
believed what these deaths tell us is
that we had community transmission
probably to a significant degree far
earlier than we had known dr. Vaisman
yani says modeling is partially based on
our behavior so we all have a say and
what happens next if we stay home when
we are asked to stay home if we wash our
hands if we use masks well we might
change the trajectory of this epidemic
we cannot change the path of a hurricane
for an epidemic we can change that
trajectory it's not the only study that
found that this virus was likely
circulating in the United States a lot
earlier than we suspected a recent study
out of Mount Sinai found that the virus
was likely present in New York City as
early as late January Anthony Wow John
thank you